so this year is the 20th anniversary for
Pokemon and we're celebrating it this
week with the release of pokin players
can perform various techniques you might
remember from a Pokemon series such as
special moves in mega evolutions which
can be built up from attacks using eight
resonance gauge players can also use
support Pokemon to give them special
benefits such as buffs and attack or
defense Nintendo also confirmed everyone
who buys an early copy of the game will
get a shadow Mewtwo amiibo card tapping
the card on the Wii U gamepad brings up
the playable shadow Mewtwo character in
the game note that this is an amigo card
not a figure shadow Mewtwo amiibo toy
hasn't been announced just a bummer you
become the Pokemon on the tenth need for
speed comes to PC this week supporting
steering wheels from Logitech
thrustmaster and fanatec as well as
gamepads like the Xbox one controller
ghost games confirmed that need for
speed on PC will run at higher frame
rates than consoles which is the least
they can do but that's only if your
computer can handle it the game sports
an unlocked framerate capable of
delivering 4k visuals now the trailer
boasts that it's an unlocked frame rate
but wouldn't it be nicer if we just
lived in a world without was expected
kick it into high gear on the fifteenth
EA sports UFC 2 adds a new knockout
physics system new character models and
a handful of fresh modes including KO
mode and ultimate team the game also
boasts a revamped career mode which lets
you create female fighters the first
game didn't do that as well as new
feature called grapple assist that helps
players master their skills so now you
can play as Ronda Rousey and take on
that much hyped bout with holly holm
sheltered comes from two-man developer
unit cube and focuses on a family who
must find their way to survive in a
deserted shelter venturing out into the
wasteland scavenge for supplies
sheltered features a crafting system RPG
mechanics for each of your family
members in a turn-based combat system
for those that can't be reasoned with
you're going to kill them sounds pretty
serious and you can take that on on the
fifteenth if you've been waiting for a
2d side scrolling Dark Souls your wait
is over salt and sanctuary offers
beautifully dark 2d hand-drawn visuals
weapons will have move sets and players
will be able to perform air attacks they
can wield two-handed weapons for
additional power and shields to defend
themselves magic and range attacks can
also be performed this game is difficult
and it's got some serious intensive boss
fights you can check that out on the
fifteenth dungeon of the endless leaps
from pc to xbox one this week you and a
team protect the generator on their
crashed ship while exploring an
ever-expanding dungeon all while facing
waves of monsters and special events as
they try to find their way out at the
start of each game you get to pick
characters with different statistics
like health and attack and defense and
then you play the game out and primarily
a turn-based matter if you can survive
long enough to even find the exit one of
the players has to get and carry a
crystal to it while the other player
basically just protects them from dying
it ain't no walk in the park and that's
out on the 16th and obviously you can't
forget to mention enron Kagura estival
versus a game overflowing with snooty
ninja moves expected clothes clearing
combos and in the description it says
storyline this game is just oozing with
plot all previous characters return but
still none of them look legal you get
new moves and upgraded skills and new
characters and there's your challenges
like fighting this squid which is
uncomfortable or fitting into this
basketball hoop you can't fit in there
bust out your waifu pillows on the 15th
so that's it for this week if you guys
are interested in seeing gameplay of
salt and sanctuary we actually covered
it last year at e3 you guys can look
that up there's a map packs it enjoy
senran kagura anime as hell